after the death of George Floyd were
taking a look at the history of the fear
of black men in American society and how
it often ends in violence against them
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller shows us just some of
the unjust and racist accusations over
the years it's a long timeline she's in
New York's Union Square they seen a
protest over Floyd's death Michelle good
morning to you good morning Gail as you
all know racial inequalities reveal
themselves in many ways throughout
American society but nowhere is it more
prevalent than in the criminal justice
system where black men often find
themselves on the wrong side of the law
because someone has falsely accused them
something needs to happen we're at the
point where we're not being killed every
day
protesters around the world have taken
to the streets to call out police
brutality and the systemic racism
against black people my sign says white
silence equals white violence and I want
everybody to recognize that because
white people are the people oppressing
black people the problems were exposed
with the killing of George Floyd
allegedly by police in Minneapolis
and once again with last week's now
infamous 9-1-1 call by Amy Cooper to New
York City police after a black
birdwatcher asked her to leash her dog
he's recording me and my dog the list of
false claims against african-american
men goes back decades 1989 in Boston
Charles Stewart shot and killed his
pregnant wife and wounded himself but
told police a black man did it a murder
is South Carolina's mother five years
later in 1994 Susan Smith claims she was
carjacked by a black man who took off
with her two young sons in the backseat
and last month in Florida after the
drowning of a nine year-old autistic boy
allegedly by his mom according to police
the mother Patricia Ripley as you
mentioned made up this story about her
son Alejandro getting abducted by two
black men why is it that we would be so
quick to blame black folks in these
cases for things they didn't do well
it's because they all knew that that
would or at least they felt that that
would be believed author and educator
Tim Wise says it's not fear that drives
people to conflate blackness with crime
but power and a disregard for some
people of color American history is one
in which white Americans by and large
have been taught to have indifference or
even contempt for black life we have
defined the country as a white nation
where people of color are here on a
guest pass and it's a guest pass that we
think we can revoke CBS News contributor
Abram X kandi is a professor at American
University he says since the Jim Crow
era white people have had the right of
using the police to their advantage they
recognize that they had the privilege to
call a police officer with the belief
that the police officer even if they're
in the wrong will be on their side it's
a painful history that educator Jane
Elliott has been trying to fight for
more than 50 years
people her famous brown eyes versus blue
eyes experiment assigned heightened
status to third grade students based on
those arbitrary parameters in an effort
to teach them about discrimination it's
time to recognize people as they are
which as is human beings we're all in
the same race you need to educate
yourself as to the truth of this
situation instead of believing the lie
that has been promulgated in this
country for the last 400 years the lie
of several different races and the lie
of the rightness of whiteness it's a lot
she does not mince words but I want to
tell you about a study published last
year by multiple universities have found
that black men are two-and-a-half times
more likely to be killed by police than
white men but that study also found that
police killings are the sixth leading
cause of death among men of all races
ages 25 to 29 think about that I am
thinking about that Michelle I really I
look forward to the day where black
people in this country are not first
judged as suspects and not law-abiding
citizens first I worry now when my son
goes to walk his dog in LA and the
climate that we're living in I get very
worried just when he steps outside doing
ordinary things to walk the dog and he
said to me that somebody said to him be
tired be exhausted but never be
diminished so I try to hold on to that
but these are very scary times very
frightening times are living in I thank
you for that story it's very important
to show the history thank you very much